dernière ligne droite pour les cadeaux
de noël dans cette enseigne spécialisée
à rambouillet les jeux de société sont
toujours autant plébiscité les tendances
cette année seront notamment en lien
avec le petit écran ou encore avec
l'actualité littéraire et
cinématographique en fête cette année
les 20 ans de la sortie du livre harry
potter est également la sortie des
animaux fantastiques numéro 2 est sorti
au cinéma récemment ce qui fait qu'on a
une forte demande sur les produits et de
toute la gamme harry potter donc que ce
soit les lego les
figurines articulées et tous les
produits dérivés les traditionnels lego
et playmobil auront également leur place
sous le sapin tout comme les poupées
surprise lol les hachey molle ou encore
les loisirs créatifs
nous on a deux filles donc c'est
principalement des poupées les petits
chiens et puis on essaie de jouer un
petit peu en reprend les rollers et
protections aux nations une fourchette
de 200 euros à peu près pour tout le
monde donc on est bien
premier poste de dépenses les cadeaux de
noël représenteront en moyenne cette
année 340 euros des dépenses anticipées
pour deux français sur trois qui en
majorité respecte à la lettre les
souhaits des enfants
on est encore sur du découpage de
catalogue où les enfants vont faire leur
liste et effectivement ça va être le qui
vont être à l'origine de la demande et
la fille sa liste donc d'après la liste
dont on partagera ma fille et moi chaque
français prévoient en moyenne d'acheter
plus de 8 cadeaux pas de doute la hotte
du père noël risquent encore d'être bien
remplie cette année